[Music]
on this thursday night reinforcements
for coveted ravaged alberta
the military help expected as
overwhelmed and understaffed hospitals
change the way they care for patients
there comes a physical and temporal
limitation the pressure on everyone to
get vaccinated
elected but rejected i think it's
ridiculous like what an absolute scandal
multiplying calls for an mp elect to
step down
europe's plug for a
one-size-fits-all approach it's for the
consumers the push for a universal
charging cable and the push back from a
tech giant
and what is she doing a heart-stopping
close call on the tracks
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us more than a year and a half into this
pandemic the federal government is once
again gearing up to help a province in
crisis
ottawa says it has approved a request
from alberta for more medical staff and
military airlifts for coveted patients a
source tells global news the deployment
could begin in the next 24 to 48 hours
and the support is desperately needed
with hospital beds filling up fast
non-urgent surgeries have been postponed
and healthcare staff are stretched to
the limit
even with more beds added alberta's icus
are at 89 capacity
with icu beds being put in operating
rooms and alberta one crisis away from
doctors being forced to make the
difficult decisions on who gets a
ventilator and who does not the city of
calgary is going a step further and
making vaccine passports mandatory
heather urux west has tonight's top
story
for calgary city councilor and mayoral
candidate jeff davison alberta's coveted
crisis has hit close to home for us
we've got a little girl who
will require surgery it's now been
pushed to even have a conversation about
when that surgery would be we have no
idea when the surgery will take place we
have no idea if the next evaluation will
get pushed and the question we keep
asking is how long are we supposed to
wait it's with six-year-old amelia in
mind that davidson joined most of his
council colleagues wednesday in passing
a city bylaw to make the province's
opt-in vaccine passport program
mandatory for most non-essential
businesses in the city there's a lot of
confusion with respect to what's going
on and so trying to make it simpler and
easier on
all of the folks working in small
business and in our city but it's not
just people in calgary getting sick from
covet 19. following rumors of a coveted
exposure party in his community the
mayor of edson alberta a town of 8 000
with just 58 vaccine coverage took to
social media to urge residents to get
the shot
we have many residents in icu in
edmonton and unfortunately three edson
area residents have lost their lives in
recent days due to covet we just keep
pulling beds out of nowhere and we're
planning on on further expanding the
unit into the general or and adding
another intensive care doctor the
province has now more than doubled its
current icu capacity but those extra
beds carry a cost this altered care
delivery document explains how patient
care has changed patients who were
repositioned every two hours are now
moved every four a chart check
medication review that once happened
every 12 hours now every 24. i'm not
saying we're cutting corners but there
comes a physical and temporal limitation
to how much care you can deliver under
the current system it's why federal help
will soon be on the way as the province
and its people continue to struggle
under the still surging fourth wave
heather urex west global news calgary
and it's not just alberta dealing with a
major surge of coven 19. next door in
saskatchewan case numbers are rising
fast 399 out of every 100 000 people in
that province are infected with covid19
and hospitals are feeling the pressure a
record 273 people are hospitalized with
the virus more than 75 percent of them
are not fully vaccinated and adults are
being moved into pediatric icu beds
nathaniel dove reports on alarming
trends and the appeals for more people
to get their shot
maverick
needs a heart echo done kerry bell guard
upon a cha is heartbroken her
five-year-old grandson and 25-year-old
daughter are both in hospital with covet
19.
her daughter isn't vaccinated and she
says she's worried about other family
members one has
tested negative
we're not sure on the baby yet
but he seems to be doing good patients
are now in the children's icu in
saskatoon and in regina's cardiac center
and it could have been prevented nearly
84 of all new infections and
hospitalizations in our province in
august were in unvaccinated or partially
vaccinated people doctors point to july
11th when the provincial government
lifted all restrictions since then case
numbers have spiked from 44 to averaging
more than 400 per day for more than a
week and vaccination uptake slowed but
is picking up again premier scott moe
has said it's the fault of the
unvaccinated but it's beginning to look
more like the children's pandemic
children who are too young to get their
shots 98 of school-aged children with
covet live in households with
unvaccinated or partially vaccinated
parents some new guidelines are coming
on october 1st most businesses will
require proof of vaccination or a recent
negative cova test to enter
the saskatoon ymca says that's not
sufficient it will only accept proof of
vaccination we don't know how long the
tests are good for we don't know where
their tests are going to be done and we
don't know how people are going to show
that they've taken those tests
guidelines prevent belgard uponecha from
visiting her daughter and grandson she
hopes they and others stay safe let's
just hope that they get better and
people realize how important it is to
get vaccinated nathaniel dove global
news saskatoon
in ontario more than 170 workers at
windsor hospitals have been placed on
unpaid leave for not getting vaccinated
windsor regional hospital and hotel dear
grace healthcare both mandated all
employees to have at least one dose by
wednesday
all unvaccinated workers now have until
early october to get their first shot
and if they fail to meet the new
deadline they'll be terminated or have
their facility privileges suspended and
the u.s is on the verge of giving covet
19 booster shots to hundreds of millions
of americans today the cdc approved
additional doses of the pfizer vaccine
for those over 18 who are at high risk
for severe illness as jackson proskow
reports there's still a debate about
whether the shots are necessary for the
general public at a time when so many
are still unvaccinated
in a crushing fourth wave fears of
waning vaccine efficacy have led to the
rapid push for booster shots with u.s
regulators approving a third dose for
some of those who received the pfizer
vaccine seniors over 65 and those over
age 18 who are at higher risk due to a
pre-existing condition like you i'm
approaching this decision with an
interest in doing what's right for the
public health
it's confusing because last month the
white house suggested extra shots would
be widely approved eight months after
your second shot
get a booster shot scientists still
aren't sure if the general public needs
that extra dose there are benefits and
potential risks there's a concern about
younger people particularly men
because of a very rare adverse event
called myocarditis boosters could be
vital for the most vulnerable but they
will not solve the fundamental problem
of the pandemic we are not seeing health
care systems in distress
because people are missing their
boosters we are seeing hospitals on the
brink of collapse because the vast
majority of hospitalized patients with
covet are unvaccinated
the question is even more complicated in
canada where the federal government
still hasn't made a decision on boosters
for the general public
canadians saw their vaccine doses mixed
and matched and spaced further apart
than in the u.s
scientists are studying whether that may
have created longer lasting immunity so
perhaps our general population really
won't need
this booster or third dose except if you
are
one of the vulnerable
peoples that we're looking at
despite all the unknowns widespread
interest in booster shots is unlikely to
fade away as the delta variant
challenges our defenses
jackson prosko global news washington
contentious races are still playing out
as the final ballots are counted in a
few tight ridings after monday's federal
election
in one ontario riding it's not the vote
tally but the candidate who won that's
causing controversy kevin wong says he
will sit as an independent after being
dropped by the liberal party over a
sexual assault charge that was also
dropped abigail beeman on the growing
calls for the rookie politician to
resign
he got in like as a trojan horse he
hasn't stepped foot in the house of
commons yet and calls are mounting for
mp elect kevin vuong to keep out it's
an uncomfortable situation the liberal
party dropped him as a candidate just
two days before the election over a
dropped sexual assault charge they say
they learned about from the toronto star
too late to take his name off the ballot
and too late for thousands who had
already cast advance or mail-in votes oh
my god i think it's ridiculous like what
an absolute scandal vuong did not
respond to an interview request so far
sticking to a wednesday statement saying
he plans to address the sexual assault
allegations at a later date more wholly
and that he was involved in a casual but
intimate relationship i understood
everything to be consensual in a tweet
someone who says he was campaign chair
called wong's stance disgraceful and
accuses him of point blank lying pretty
shocking pretty weird that we're
presented by him right now but
nothing i could really do there are a
few options the federal liberal writing
association is calling for his
resignation and a by-election so is his
ndp opponent in the writing and a
resignation petition has a growing
number of signatures the provincial
ontario liberal leader says vuong
shouldn't take the open seat and that he
won't have a place in the provincial
party if wang doesn't resign process
gurus raise another point the house does
reserve the right to boot anybody out if
they want to
but they don't want to very often for
obvious reasons expulsion a
parliamentary power so rarely used it
hasn't happened since a 1947 cold war
spying case and previously applied to
louis riel twice
i think a good case could be made people
feel uncomfortable having him as their
mp or would feel perhaps uncomfortable
approaching him with a concern uh as
their elected representative then the
house would in that case have a
justification for removing him even in
the absence of a conviction as of now
vuong plans to sit as an independent as
pressure keeps mounting for him to step
down
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the defeat of fisheries minister
bernadette jordan in the federal
election may be a sign a resolution is
needed in nova scotia's ongoing lobster
dispute
ever since the historic marshall
decision in 1999 fishers and indigenous
communities and their commercial
counterparts have quarreled over who
gets to fish and when
but now new developments have some
feeling optimistic here's ross lord
with fears of more violence in upcoming
weeks and months supporters of
indigenous fishing rights covered the
department of fisheries and oceans sign
with their own message let's take our
livelihood back
it needs to come back
needs to come back to where it belongs
with native people for those fishing
outside of the commercial lobster season
with the backing of a 1999 supreme court
ruling there is confusion dfo has been
seizing their lobster traps since a
reworked treaty fishery began last month
i
don't know the direction to take because
our hands are tied in every which way
so
that being said go hunt and go fish i'm
facing charges for fishing outside of
season i'm facing charges for selling
catch that i'm supposedly not allowed to
last year's indigenous lobster fishery
was met by violence from commercial
harvesters traps were sabotaged there
was physical violence and the lobster
plant connected to indigenous fishers
was burnt to the ground harvesters on
both sides of the dispute blame dfo for
not clarifying how indigenous and
commercial fishers can make their living
in these waters peacefully the fisheries
minister nova scotia mp bernadette
jordan was defeated in monday's election
raising hopes the next minister will
promote an atmosphere of respect between
the two sides and i think that's exactly
where a new minister can come to play
here is that they have a clear role to
bring us all to the table and engage in
a dialogue process that's ultimately
what we should expect as canadians is to
work these things out with dialogue
around a negotiation table otherwise the
weeks and months ahead could look a lot
like last year
ross lord global news
the u.s special envoy to haiti has quit
over what he calls the inhumane
deportation of migrants and a warning
some of these images are disturbing
daniel foote says he will not be
associated with the united states
inhumane counterproductive decision to
deport thousands of haitian refugees
from the u.s mexico border the u.s says
it condemns border agents aggressive use
of horse rains to intimidate migrants an
investigation is underway and at least
one policy has already changed
one we feel those images are horrible
and horrific i can also convey to you
that the secretary also conveyed to
civil rights leaders earlier this
morning that we would no longer be using
horses in del rio
the texas governor has ordered a
symbolic wall of state vehicles to stop
more haitians from arriving the size of
the texas camp has been dramatically
reduced to less than 5 000 people from
14 000 as processing ramps up more than
1400 haitians have been deported since
sunday
quebec's proposed language law overhaul
coming up the backlash from both sides
over bill 96.
the quebec government has started
consultations on changes to the
province's language laws bill 96 is
called an ambitious upgrade of
legislation first passed in 1977 to
protect and promote the use of french
some of the new law's most controversial
measures involve english speakers
education rights michael couture reports
le francaise
bill 96 is a big one it's not only one
hundred pages long but it aims to
address what the quebec government calls
a decline of french in the province
systematic dua
systemic bilingualism in the public
sector must stop says minister simon
jolene barrett and bill 96 is his
solution it would require government
agencies to use french exclusively in
written and oral communication there
would be few exceptions but businesses
for example would have to ensure the
quote net predominance of french on all
sides
changes that english language rights
groups feel go too far it doesn't
promote french what it actually does is
eliminate our
individual rights and freedoms and not
just for english speakers for all
quebecers so you'd think defenders of
the french language like former minister
louise beauduin would be happy with the
bill
she doesn't think it goes far enough
the minister must show more courage to
get there said beauduin adding the bill
cannot be moderate and reasonable given
the state of french in quebec
statistics canada projects a drop in the
percentage of quebecers whose mother
tongue is french from 79 percent in 2011
to 70 percent in 2036.
that erosion is the impetus for this
bill but some warn of more dire
consequences i think we're going to see
a rising count of of indigenous people
that die the director of montreal's
native women's shelter says the tragic
death of joyce eshequan is a prime
example of how language barriers limit
the services indigenous people receive
this is before bill 96 right so we can
go to the police
and it would be refused
services because of the language
it's concrete it's happened despite
concerns bill 96 will violate the
charter of rights premier francois
preemptively invoke the non-withstanding
clause protecting the bill from court
challenges
farah
michael couture in ottawa thank you mike
there's a new development in the snc
level criminal investigation two former
company executives are facing charges
for allegedly paying bribes to obtain a
contract the men charged are former snc
lavala vice president noma
and kamal francis a former vice
president at snc lavala international
the montreal engineering giant and its
international business arm are also
facing several charges including fraud
against the government snc lavalier was
previously charged with bribery and
fraud in relation to its past work in
libya which was at the center of the
high profile 2019 battle between prime
minister justin trudeau and then
attorney general jody wilson-raybould
still ahead from hudson's bay to the
west coast the new deal to dress team
canada
canada's olympic and paralympic athletes
have a new official outfitter lululemon
will dress the team team canada that is
starting with the 2022 winter olympics
the deal will last through the 2028
summer games the vancouver-based company
will provide outfits for the opening and
closing ceremonies medal ceremonies and
to wear around the athletes village
hudson bay company had outfitted
athletes since 2006.
now it should be common sense but
officials in the netherlands want to
drill the message home do not take risks
at train crossings the country's rail
agency released this video of a woman's
incredibly close call with the train now
you can see she crossed the tracks while
the barriers were down and the warning
lights were on
universal charger next the eu's plan to
pull the plug on e-waste
have you ever fumbled around with a
bunch of tangled chargers to find the
one that fits your latest gadget well
politicians in the eu are pushing for a
single universal charging method as mike
delay reports it's an effort to cut down
on approximately 50 million tons of
electronic waste produced every year
evolution isn't always pretty take the
power cable it went from two simple
prongs to all manner of shapes and
configurations
you'd think we'd have learned our lesson
finding a phone in the car yet when cell
phones burst onto the market no two
products seem to like
oh hey there fast forward to today and
virtually every house has a drawer or a
bucket just like this
filled with a noodle-like mess of cables
i know what this is for
probably a camera this one
cell phone maybe
back in the bucket
[Music]
how many cables you have at home do you
think from past devices that no longer
work
i'd say i got like a part about half a
backpack full yeah why won't you throw
them away because you never know when
you're going to need them this is the
dream i know well the european union for
one sees the whole thing as a nightmare
and is drafting rules that would mandate
one universal power cable for all phones
cameras and tablets it didn't work in
middle earth one
ring to rule them all
but maybe it can work here the eu
argument is compelling for consumers it
makes life simpler and it will help
reduce waste so which cable that would
be the usb type-c this one which could
leave apple and its lightning cable out
in the cold or at least in the drawer
with all those other cables
could that mean no more 50 chargers with
every phone upgrade apple is resisting
saying the move stifles innovation
everyone with one charger can you
imagine a world with everyone with one
charger yes it doesn't make sense
the fight for power
rarely does
mike relay global news toronto
it'd make life so much more simple that
is global national for this thursday
night i'm pharyn asser thank you so much
for spending part of your evening with
us tonight's your canada is white shell
provincial park in southeastern manitoba
we love seeing your canada so please
email us your pictures viewers at
globalnational.com until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and each other
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]